le 19/20 continue voici le rappel des
titres l'inquiétude grandit autour de la
marée noire au large du maroc 200 mille
tonnes de pétrole sont encore dans les
soutes du navire et peuvent se déverser
à tout moment dans la mer notre invité
brice lalonde
le secrétaire d'état à l'environnement
revient du maroc où il a suivi
l'évolution de la situation aux côtés
des autorités
la frontière soviéto iranienne théâtre
de scènes de violence depuis le week-end
dernier s'est trouvé cnic désherber
djian embarras signons soviétique
le calme est revenu en roumanie dix
jours après les affrontements à
timisoara la ville martyre l'aide
humanitaire s'organise
reportage au coeur des hôpitaux de la
ville enfin faut-il se méfier de l'eau
du robinet oui dans certaines villes on
répond la revue que choisir dans
quelques minutes ils encaissent à
poitiers mais tout de suite les acte
d'inconscience commis sur plusieurs
autoroutes près de marseille des blocs
de pierre ou de béton sont lâchés depuis
des passerelles par des inconnus sur les
voitures qui circulent sur l'autoroute
au total dix personnes ont été blessées
dont deux grièvement
depuis ce week-end la police recherche
activement les auteurs de ces gestes
insensés de marseille
gabrielle bree
ce soir-là jannet salue mille heures des
enfants rentrer à marseille par
l'autoroute de marignane une fin de
soirée tout à fait paisible
tout à coup le drame à la sortie d'un
tunnel des individus cachés sur un pont
long sur leur voiture un parpaing de 15
kg tout se passe en une fraction de
seconde j'ai rien vu
si rim vu ça a été une flash et
j'ai ouvert les yeux j'ai vu mon mari
avec la voiture arrêtée le pare-brise
cassés je me suis retrouvée couchée la
voiture mais j'ai pas senti mon épaule
qui était cassé j'ai simplement cru que
j'étais couché parce que le siège lui
même était cassé j'ai ouvert les yeux
j'avais la jambe de mon fils sous sous
mes yeux l'os dehors complètement à cet
endroit là les pierres sont nombreuses
sur le sol mais ce qui inquiète ce soir
les services de police c'est la récidive
depuis une quinzaine de jours de jets de
parfums et de blocs de béton
jusqu'ici les jets de pierre était sans
doute le fait de gamins malveillants
désormais les services de police en sont
sûrs
il s'agit là d'une bande d'individus
déterminés qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement les lieux et qui en a rien
dedans sévissent dans un périmètre d'une
dizaine de kilomètres à ce jour une
quarantaine de plainte a été déposée
pour l'instant il ne s'agissait que de
bris de pare brise
mais cette fois il ya menace survie
humaine le parquet d'aix-en-provence a
donc ouvert une information judiciaire
en invoquant le missile volontaire en
attendant un dispositif policier
extrêmement minutieux été mise en place
les individus en question pourrait
dit-on être arrêté dans les heures qui
viennent à l'étranger très violents
affrontements depuis dimanche à la
frontière entre l'union soviétique et
l'iran
les troubles ont été provoqués par les
nationalistes azéri qui réclament de
part et d'autre de la frontière la
création d'une grande république
autonome en azerbaïdjan où il est
question des nationalités rebondi en
urss et cela embarrasse très
sérieusement à mikhaïl gorbatchev à tel
point que ces troubles ont été commentés
commettant des actes de déstabilisation
le point avec les mauvais rénale depuis
trois jours des troubles extrêmement
graves ont lieu sur la quasi-totalité de
la frontière entre l'iran et
l'azerbaïdjan
l'une des principales république
islamique de l'urss des milliers
d'émeutiers se seraient attaqués au
poste de garde situé sur les 700 km de
frontière
d'après la télé soviétique qui a relaté
les événements sans en préciser les
raisons
les affrontements seraient le fait
d'éléments extrémistes
lebron les drogués mais les izvestia
citant de hauts responsables locaux du
kgb ont reconnu l'aspect nationalistes
des manifestations au cours de ces trois
jours d'émeutes
les manifestants ont réclamé l'ouverture
des frontières et la réunion
l'action des deux azerbaïdjanais au viêt
iq et iraniens la situation a été jugée
suffisamment grave pour provoquer
l'envoi de troupes soviétiques
tout au long de la frontière difficile
bien entendu de prévoir l'évolution de
la situation
l'iran dont les relations se sont
améliorées avec l'urss ne chercherait
pas dit-on à exploiter cette tension
religieuse
ces derniers jours moscou a fait savoir
très fermement que la renaissance des
nationalismes qu'a connu l'europe de
l'est devaient s'arrêter aux frontières
de l'urss
reste à savoir si les musulmans
soviétique auront entendu le message
la pollution au large du maroc le
pétrolier iranien car hx1 cas continuent
aujourd'hui à déverser toutes les heures
deux tonnes de son chargement dans la
mer le remorquage du pétrolier se
poursuit dans des conditions rendues
très difficiles par la dégradation de la
situation climatique des offres
atteignant 45 km/heure des vagues de
huit mètres de hauteur autant de
conditions qui font craindre le pire
alors que le navire transporte toujours
200 mille tonnes de pétrole en fait le
cas de saint se dirige vers les îles du
cap vert pour trouver un abri afin de
faciliter les réparations et concernant
la nappe d'hydrocarbures qui s'étendait
sur 65 mille hectares et miel s'est
fractionné et ne touchera les virages
que ponctuellement brice lalonde
secrétaire d'état à l'environnement est
ce soir l'invité de la rédaction vous
avez suivi l'évolution de la situation
précisément aux côtés des autorités
marocaines
on parle beaucoup des 70 mille tonnes de
pétrole qui se sont déjà échappées du
navire catherine le disais à l'instant
il reste encore 200 mille tonnes de ce
pétrole dans les soutes que va-t-il se
passer c'est 200 mille tonnes
risque-t-elle de se déverser à leur tour
dans la mer et puis je suis très
pessimiste pour le navire l'épave est
plutôt optimiste pour les côtes
marocaines
c'est vrai il ya un vrai problème j'ai
survolé le pétrolier hier il a trés trés
mauvaise mine il est à moitié brûlé il
est rouillé il a une un grand trou il
date la jcct le gouvernail est bloqué il
ya six remorqueurs qui essaye de le
tirer et j'ai téléphoné plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui à la société de remorquage
néerlandaise qui m'a confirmé que si
dans l'est dans les jours qui viennent
dans les heures qui viennent
on ne trouvait pas ports ou des eaux
territoriales pour accueillir un pétrole
le pétrolier et bien il y avait rien à
faire or je ne vois pas qui va
accueillir ce pétrolier il faut
l'alliance avec m de tirant d'eau
ils polluent le pétrole s'échappe il est
gouverneur
on peut envisager que ce pétrolier reste
au large et continuer à déverser tout
son pétrole dans la mer
c'est une hypothèse qui reste valable
attribuant la société au marquage m'a
dit si on en use qu'il arrive pas à
trouver un endroit si aucun état
n'accepterait ne vois pas qui va
accepter dans les circonstances
actuelles parce que personne ne peut
aller voir ce qui se passe si aucun état
n'accepterait de recevoir le tanker
on croit rien faire ça veut dire à ce
moment là qu israël qui risquent d'être
abandonnés depuis l'épave est alors avec
ses 200 mille tonnes il va se promener
par long des côtes
elles seront donc moins touché que prévu
par les côtes nous avons envoyé un
navire des experts j'ai reçu les
premiers coups de téléphone tout à
l'heure ils sont plutôt rassurants en ce
sens que ils me disent avec le vent qui
s'est levé il semble impossible
d'échapper à la marée noire il y aura du
pétrole qui arrivera sur les côtes
marocaines mais moins que prévu
parce que les nappes paraissent assez
mince donc c'est assez rassurant et ça
veut dire qu'il faut se donner du mal
surtout pour protéger les zones qui sont
les plus fragiles
en tout cas des barrages flottants
risque de devenir inutile dans ce cas là
les marocains n'ont recours quelques à
lembras coppel et pourtant l'amoco cadiz
ça ne remonte sa remontée à 12 oh oui
vous avez quand il faut l'intégrer dans
les 48 heures quand on n'intervient pas
dans les 48 heures tout ce qui est le
matériel chimique
ça ne marche pas le pétrole se mélangent
occupe une surface immense et on se sent
tout petit et en effet on peut protéger
des zones qu'on et parcs à huîtres port
particulier alors là on protège mais
tout le reste est immense il faut
nettoyer oui en effet il faut le faire
alors voilà pour les faits reste
maintenant les polémiques multiples qui
ont éclaté autour du remorquage et
autour du renflouement de ce navire
pétrolier donc iranien alors une fois de
plus on a perdu de précieuses heures
avant toute intervention
à croire que les tragiques précédent
n'est malheureusement servi à rien
pierre mader un bateau chargé de brut
iraniens armés par des grecs mais servie
par des philippins menaçant des côtes
espagnoles puis marocaine alors que les
assureurs anglais discute avec les
sauveteurs néerlandais résultat de cette
distribution internationale des heures
et des heures de discussion
d'atermoiements pour un scénario hélas
sans surprise mais qui est toujours sa
salle signature
ce 16 mars 78 un pétrolier libérien de
230 mille tonnes en panne du gouvernail
dérive à quelques milles des côtes
bretonnes
un remorqueur allemand lui propose un
contrat d'assistance 5h de laborieuses
négociations avec le capitaine et les
armateurs avant que les premières à marc
soient lancés trop de temps perdu à 23h
l'amoco cadiz talonne les rochers de
portsall alors l'histoire balbutie le
scénario bégaie le drame de la bretagne
souliers n'aura servi à rien
paradoxalement si le droit international
a évolué très lentement trop tard pour
cette fois ci une nouvelle convention a
finalement été signé en avril dernier en
avril 1989 et elle a notamment pour
objet d'allouer aux sauveteurs une
indemnisation spéciale destinée à
rémunérer le sauveteur dans les efforts
qu'il a faits pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'environnement coût de la
pollution de l'amoco pour l'état
français 2 milliards de francs chiffre
d'affaires de l'assurance maritime
mondial 35 milliards de francs 17 fois
plus et il y à un naufrage par jour sur
toutes les mers de la planète à brice
lalonde combien de temps va durer encore
ce scandale en mer les pétroliers qui un
peu partout dans le monde déversent leur
pétrole comme ça au gré de quelques
armateurs
le pétrolier et iraniens il est armé par
des grecs il n'y a aucune réglementation
internationale il y en a malheureusement
ça ne suffit pas et puis d'excellents
jeux international personne n'est
responsable c'est vraiment la loi de la
jungle
c'est totalement transnationales comme
vous l'avez dit la cargaison le marin le
le chef le capitaine d'armateurs le
propriétaire les assureurs le remorqueur
tout ça ces nationalités différentes
ces transnationales mais l'alimentation
c'est on ne connaît que les zones
territoriales les états aidés que c'est
en haute mer plus personne n'est
responsable faire ce qu'on veut alors ça
c'est la date qui doit agir maintenant
les états il faut qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités il faut aller plus vite
l'organisation maritime internationale
doit proposer des recommandations et il
faut qu'on trouve un système dans lequel
la communauté internationale se donne le
droit d'intervenir quand il ya une
menace dans les eaux internationales
au fond la planète il faut bien
quelqu'un l'a protégé ici on s'organise
pas c'est vraiment mal parti et la
communauté européenne doit donner
l'exemple d'el d
mais on le dit ça après chaque
catastrophe oui on a déjà avancé et sous
présidence française on a déjà fait
avant c'est un tout petit peu les
résolutions c'est pareil pour les
transports de matières chimiques on a
dit fut car il faut la plage c'est une
cascade dans qui coiffe ah non c'est pas
possible comme ça il faut absolument
sauver des avantages bien c'est vrai que
c'est lent et on a eu dix années
difficiles je vais vous dire moi parce
que les nouveaux pétroliers de la
nouvelle réglementation sont
obligatoires mais après qu'on a fini
d'utiliser les vieux et donc pendant 10
ans on va encore avoir des compagnies
pétrolières qui veulent gagner de
l'argent qu'ils vont user les vielles
jusqu'à la corde
merci brice lalonde d'avoir accepté de
répondre à toutes ces questions
l'actualité internationale en bref voici
maintenant les télégrammes de l'étranger
préparer commenter ce soir par
marie-odile daniels
des fillon nouveau pouvoir bulgare des
milliers de nationalistes se sont
mobilisés contre la restitution des
droits de la minorité musulmane
d'origine nature en 1984 les droit de
choisir son nom sa religion ses coutumes
ou de parler une autre langue que le
bulgare avait été interdite à cette
communauté est depuis l'été dernier près
de 300 mille musulmans de bulgarie avec
immigrés vers la turquie
vive condamnation par le gouvernement
nicaraguayen de l' attaque qui a coûté
la vie à deux religieuses une américaine
et boukhara doyenne lundi dernier dans
le sud du pays selon mme al agua
l'embuscade aurait été menée par des
guérilleros de la contra statu quo au
panama les négociations sur le sort du
général noriega n'ont toujours pas
abouti
mais selon le président panaméen le
vatican devrait remettre très vite
manuel noriega aux autorités américaines
guillermo endara aussi annoncé que les
états unis qui commence le rapatriement
de leurs troupes offrirait au panama une
aide d'urgence pour pallier les
conséquences de l'intervention militaire
le calme est revenu en roumanie où les
autorités ont abrogé les décrets les
plus répressifs du régime coc secours
dans la ville martyre de timisoara les
hôpitaux restent bond est occupée par
les nombreuses victimes des
manifestations du 16 décembre et
l'action humanitaire internationale s'y
révèle plus que jamais indispensable
exemple avec cette équipe française
partie du sud de la france il y a qu un
cinq jours pour rallier timisoara l'aide
qu'elle veuille apporter chez tout à
fait adaptée au besoin une condition
essentielle pour que cette ville
meurtrie puissent non plus survivre mais
vivre denys jean claude n'aura timisoara
la ville martyre la révolution roumaine
a commencé ici mais la population a payé
cher son désir de liberté par des
massacres aux chiffres encore imprécis
mais largement surestimée
l'ancien hôpital hôpital
ouais
nous allons médicament arrive à point
nommé ils sont triés et le contenu des
cartons et inscrit dessus en français et
en roumain pour l'hôpital de timisoara
ce qu'on voie express est le premier à
être aussi précis il correspond
exactement à la demande
certains médicaments seront utilisés
immédiatement dans les corps des morts
et des blessés voilà ce qu'on retrouve
des balles dum-dum interdites par la
convention de genève
elles sont à dassier et aplatit au bout
dans la chair humaine elles se
comportent comme de véritables ellis de
hachoir
pendant ce temps la ville de timisoara
reprend son souffle le pays le plus
pauvre d'europe et apprend à parler et à
rêver la place de l'opéra est devenue la
place de la victoire
les distributions se succèdent au rythme
des arrivages de toute l'europe et
surtout des convois français les
roumains on retrouve le goût du chocolat
et des oranges réservé auparavant aux
privilégiés du régime
faut-il se méfier de l'eau du robinet
oui si l'on en croit le mensuel que
choisir qui révèle après de multiples
analyses la présence de nitrates mais
aussi de cocktails inquiétant de
pesticides et de solvants chlorés villes
citées par que choisir poitiers et bien
sur place les autorités compétentes
crient au scandale et s'apprête à
commander une contre-expertise tout de
suite l'enquète de leurs cinq prières
lot de poitiers aurait deux défauts
majeurs
elle contiendrait des halles aux formes
des dérivés chlorés mais toujours en
deçà des normes est acceptée elle
contiendrait aussi des dérivés du lin
dan un peu plus de 0,1 microgramme par
litre pour deux d'entre eux les
informations qui pourraient être
inquiétante que choisir pourtant se
défend de vouloir provoquer une psychose
qu'elle veut pas dire c'est cette eau et
ne consommer plus mais l'alertent
signifie nous disons tous les
consommateurs de poitiers faites
attention soyez exigeants sur la qualité
de l'eau dans votre ville exigeait des
analyses répétées et précise du côté du
district on reste plus que perplexe les
analyses effectuées tous les quinze
jours n'ont jamais provoquer
d'inquiétude
l'eau est bonne il est vrai que les
analyses plus poussées commandé par le
mensuel ne sont obligatoires pour les
distributeurs que depuis le 1er janvier
poitiers procédera donc assez analyse
puisque la loi n'impose
en attendant les autorités du district
contre attaque l'anc est pour eux est
tout à fait contestable
il me semble que l' enquête est tout à
fait alors je dirais révocable en tant
que méthodologie scientifique mais ces
mêmes
elle a même un caractère diffamatoire
le débat aura eu au moins une
conséquence mettre à jour le problème du
traitement de l'eau pour diminuer la
présence de chlore dans l'eau courante
il faudrait diminuer la pollution à la
source pour éviter les traitements
lourds mais là les distributeurs ne sont
plus concernés c'est toute la politique
de l'eau qui est à revoir et pas
seulement dans la région
voici à présent le tour de france de
l'actualité avec les images de 25
stations de l'a3 et les commentaires de
sophie guillou
la colère gronde aujourd'hui sur le port
d'arcachon
après une trêve de plus d'un an la
guerre s'est rallumée entre pêcheurs
français et espagnols de s'enfiler
arcachonnais ont été déchirés en pleine
nuit par des bateaux espagnols au large
du cap ferret cela représente en tout
une dizaine de kilomètres de files est
devenu inutilisable une véritable
désastre économique pour leurs
propriétaires quand ratp rime avec
sécurité c'est en effet aujourd'hui que
les agents du gipn prenaient leur
service dans les rames du métro et dans
les bus de la capitale
leur mission sécuriser les usagers et
dissuader les délinquants d'agir
le groupe d'intervention et de
protection des réseaux ne comprend pour
l'instant qu'une vingtaine d'agents mais
il devrait atteindre 60 personnes dès le
mois de mars
un mangeur de brebis sous les verrous ce
lynx de dix mois a été capturé hier soir
dans les forêts de mézos dans le jura
c'est le deuxième en une semaine
de quoi réconforter les éleveurs qui ont
perdu du bétail de steve penney trop
gourmand devoir assurer aussi les
écologistes le la nhtsa a été transféré
au parc animalier de chizé loin des
brebis tentatrice la voix l'instant la
météo complète de michel pouré grisaille
est clair si demain vous en dit plus
dans quelques minutes le programme de la
soirée sur la 3g mais avant soirée danse
avec le célèbre casse noisette de
tchaïkovski un bel est signée par neuf
et puis philippe dessaint soir 3 c'est à
22h18 le voit sur votre feuille mes
films ne dansera pas mais je vous
donnera en revanche le panorama complet
de l'information de cette journée nous
vous retrouvons demain à 19 heures pour
une nouvelle édition de 19/20 excellente
soirée à tous
bon ça
et
t